this morning I was browsing the david
pakman show subreddit this is a
discussion forum where nearly 6,000 of
our viewers and listeners are discussing
politics making suggestions for
programming on the show you can find
that at david pakman.com slash read it a
few interesting discussions that I
spotted this morning
interesting idea have Muslim Americans
join the NRA and mass to make the
organization less palatable to
conservatives I think that there is
something very very interesting there
there has always been this idea among
some pro-gun fetishists that they are
absolutists on the issue of gun rights
up to and until brown people black
people poor people sometimes start
buying guns and I am curious as to what
the reaction would be of the hardcore
white gun fetishist NRA member if a ton
of Muslim Americans all of a sudden say
we want guns we are going to start
joining the NRA so that they can defend
our right to own guns I'm guessing some
NRA supporters would welcome it and
others would probably not be so pleased
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit Dave Rubin is voting for Trump
in 2020 now that it's sort of true I
mean I watch the video and it seems that
what Ruben was saying is that if the
alternatives are crazy progressives like
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren then his
choice would be Trump now 2020 which
listen if that's what if true liberalism
is voting for Donald Trump I don't know
what liberalism is that's exactly what I
was gonna say only a true liberal would
vote for Donald Trump the last liberal
and the last liberals clearly now are
voting for Trump apparently if you
follow this logic I don't really have
too much more to say about it although
as you can see a lot of people on our
subreddit very very eager to comment
about these breaking and fascinating
developments also from the david pakman
show subreddit what makes eggs organic
depends on who you ask case in point the
definition of outdoors covered porches
or open pasture and Donald Trump's
USDA's relaxing the rules for eggs to be
certified organic yeah I I've talked
about this before and there's a former
producer
Louis for example believed there was no
such thing really as organic because no
matter where you under what conditions
you are raising livestock or growing
produce or whatever that if rain is
being used to water that it's acid rain
that's contaminated with a lot of our
pollution like is that really organic so
he had a very absolutist position that
there's no such thing as organic
whatsoever organic does mean more than
natural natural is a totally unregulated
term organic at least means something
although it's true that under the USDA
of Trump the rules are being further and
further relaxed as to what is organic
does this bother you I know you do the
cage-free thing but why I didn't know
that that's what you've claimed in the
past I do cage-free but I don't
necessarily go for the pasture-raised
eggs ah but who'd listen at this point I
don't even pretend to know what the hell
is going on and lastly from the reddit
discussion forum stefan molyneux is
telling his cult to prepare for a race
war yeah i watch this video it is filled
with history onic drama and it's just
it's crazy I don't really talk much
about stefan molyneux on the program i
don't know that i have much to say about
stefan molyneux but yeah he did a video
recently that some of our viewers were
discussing on the subreddit preparing
his his followers for what he believes
is going to be a race war and saying
you're gonna need i think he said you're
gonna need the guns and you should be
prepping and that type of thing sowing
panic I mean really I was lucky enough
to go the first 23 years of my life
without ever hearing of Stefan and then
like a month ago I heard his name three
times on one day and that was the first
time I've ever heard of him yeah well
listen once you are expert there's no
unring that Bell now that you're
familiar with them there's no way to go
back on that
join the discussion david pakman.com
slash read it I'm on there Pat is on
there a lot of good stuff happening I'll
tell you and we've got moderators too no
trolling allowed to the extent that we
notice it I'm trolling if the trolling
is subtle it gets by the moderators but
then it's maybe not really trolling
because nobody notices it